Donuts from the sky slowing down time
with cold brew and a not so secret
secret santa the rest of the episodes
are comedy gold but we're ranking just
the cold opens for Brooklyn Nine-Nine
generally a cold open describes any
episode set up that takes place before
the opening title but for the purposes
of this list and in accordance with the
unique way Brooklyn Nine-Nine handles
cold opens we've defined it as any
pre-title skit that has nothing to do
with the rest of the episode obviously
everything on this list will make you at
the very least smile but there's
something particularly special about
this cold open from the episode beach
house having detected that Captain Hulk
may be pantsless following an
uncharacteristic lunch malfunction Jake
decides to provide the squad with visual
proof cue several unsuccessful attempts
to get the captain to stand up
eventually Jake brings in a replacement
bowl of soup to entice him out of his
seat and Holt's of course wanting this
to end just admits the sitting in his
underwear Jake celebrates his victory
but also creates a second suit pants
interaction sir I need you to sign off
on look at us just three people with
pants on having a normal conversation
yep no story here well investigating a
robbery at an electronic store in the
pilot episode Jake and Amy take very
different approaches to the case Amy
questions the owner and Jake distracts
himself with anything that happens to
catch his eye having arrived early and
explaining that he already found video
footage of the robbery thanks to a nanny
cam hidden within a teddy bear Jake just
can't help himself and makes the bear
hit on Amy though not successfully all
right
detective Santiago
don't walk away from me this cold open
gives viewers a rare glimpse into the
life of Juan Rosa Diaz who has never
been known to Dole out any semblance of
personal information Rosa's surprising
desire to do something nice by taking
her boyfriend out to celebrate his
birthday spawns all sorts of weird
suggestions but it's the drunk guy in
the holding pen who has the idea Rosa
finds most attractive for a few seconds
anyway if you go to the top of the
Empire State Building that's very
romantic
maybe I will you can pee on the whole
city from up there come on
when Charles treats the squad to some
cold brew he unintentionally causes a
caffeine crisis so hilarious there's no
way it wasn't going to make this list
Captain holds Rosa and Jake all somehow
forgot that cold coffee still has
caffeine in it and went to town on
Charles's special brew and the result is
wonderful from slow-mo Charles to the
double speed Trio the writing editing
and performances are Stellar as the
caffeine fiends decide that there's
absolutely nothing wrong with them
whatsoever great excellent amazing I
feel better and I've ever felt it in a
moment in my entire life so we're all
fine
Holt's relationship has always been the
linchpin of the show ranging from their
weird father son Dynamic to the
incredible levels of pettiness they sink
to this particular cold open falls into
the former category by season six Holt
is getting a little tired of Jake's
issues with tardiness it's especially
galling when one considers the fact that
Jake's Paramore is the freaking queen of
being on time in order to underline the
importance of time keeping to his work
son Captain Holt devises a special kind
of torture six years and no matter how
hard I try I still can't get you to
understand The Importance of Being
punctual maybe you should just give up
and accept me for who I am no I will
break you right now though he's never
been one for any kind of interpersonal
touching Holt is painstakingly invented
and rehearsed the special personalized
handshake for every member of the squad
and the copy guy it's the one thing Jake
never saw coming
it's no secret that Holton Amy consider
themselves to be Head and Shoulders
Above the Rest of the squad the
superiority reaches its Zenith and the
cold open to maximum security after Hulk
gives them a brain teaser that will
reveal the location of a clandestine
meeting most of the squad slowly
trickles into the broom closet Jake is
way too full of himself over his victory
but does become suitably embarrassed
when Amy's Love of adult puzzle Camp is
brought up doesn't she go to like an
adult puzzle Camp every summer yes but
please don't bring that up I've been
throwing out her mailers perhaps the
squad shouldn't be so quick to mock
Amy's summertime activities however when
they notice that Holt and Amy are absent
they consider that they might be in the
wrong place Hitchcock and scully's
entrance confirms it Jake is unable to
contain his disappointment at
discovering he's no smarter than
Hitchcock and Scully and it's beautiful
when an incredibly extravagant gift
basket arrives the squad decides it
absolutely must be for them and they
help themselves to the basket's
decidedly decadent contents Gina always
the wisest member of the team interrupts
the feast by pointing out that the
basket is an obvious gift to Holt from
his husband Kevin Panic ensues but Jake
knows exactly how to fix it and cut to
Captain Holt opening an entirely rebuilt
basket the squad Waits with baited
breath as he inspects the replacement
contents a veritable Smorgasbord of
shiny new stationary emerges it's clear
the team has spared no expense to cover
their gluttonous tracks and it works
like a charm that man really knows me
this cold open has everything that makes
Brooklyn 99 great Stephanie Beatrice's
complete commitment to deadpan delivery
which remains intact as she tosses donut
holes at Andy Sandberg is on fire here
but the Riders apparently unsatisfied
with the already brilliant bit they take
things one step further Jake misses
catching a donut hole with his mouth and
it goes sailing off the roof but it's
only natural that the straight pastry
finds a home in scully's mouth several
floors below yup Rosa is that good and
the pride desserts falling from the sky
is literally something that must be a
dream come true for scullying
we're used to seeing Hitchcock bring
pain entirely on himself but in this
skits he's merely the innocent victim of
Jake's diabolical scheme to make the
older detective pee his pants well as
innocent as Hitchcock gets anyway Jake
relies on the try and true summer camp
method for his prank leaving Hitchcock's
hand in a bowl of lukewarm water Jake
immediately brags about his joke to the
squad when they check on the P progress
Hitchcock is somehow face down in the
water they grab him in the nick of time
but in Rose's opinion this Macabre turn
hugely improves the whole situation take
it back Jake Great Prank
when Hitchcock feels he's been badly
treated at the local coffee shop he
vents his frustrations to the gathered
Squad members he's about as worked up as
we ever see him so clearly the slide has
had a profound effect you know Hitchcock
was so concerned with how people see him
maybe there's a soft side to him that we
haven't seen before nope Jake eventually
interrupts Hitchcock to tell him the
reason for the odd treatment hey
Hitchcock your penis is hanging out
oh that's a relief when Amy fails to
appear at her desk at exactly 9am
everyone comes up with outlandish
theories to explain her uncharacteristic
tardiness Holt's contribution however
clearly pushes his imagination to its
very limits having searched his mind for
the ultimate bizarre scenario he proudly
proclaims his guess that she's running
late because of a long line at the bank
Andre brauer's deadpan delivery is
amazing but he's actually saving the
best for last when Amy walks in seconds
later the squad demands that she explain
herself there's a problem at the bank
hot damn each member of the team picks a
name for secret Santa in this
holiday-themed cold open except for Rosa
who refuses to participate where follows
belongs entirely to Andy Samberg thanks
to his absolutely perfect delivery
almost instantly identifying everyone's
secret Santa Jake proceeds to Humble
brag about his skills we even discover
he's legally changed his middle name to
Sherlock or exactly this sort of
situation rather than being impressed by
Jake's Antics Holt speaks for the whole
Squad and suggests something that shows
their displeasure at Jake ruining the
game
should we draw the names again and leave
Jake out yeah
no such a present there has never been
nor will there ever be a better cold
open than this as Jake and a haunted
looking woman examine a lineup of five
men she reveals that while she didn't
get a look at the criminal's face she
heard him singing The Backstreet boys's
1999 hits I Want It That Way Jake has
them start singing and soon it becomes a
full-blown karaoke session the idea of
having a police lineup saying I want it
that way might sound surreal but in
practice it's effortlessly perfect the
musical magic is so powerful in fact
that Jake joins in and forgets the
reason for the singing it was number
five number five killed my brother oh my
God I forgot about that part
foreign